a quarter of the estimated 90 million
dogs owned in the u.s. were brought from
a breeder according to the American Pet
Products Association most Americans are
likely to look on the internet for their
new dog we are learning the overwhelming
majority of sites advertising purebred
puppies for sale are reportedly fake Don
Dahler is here to show us how to avoid
becoming a victim of a scam Don good
morning good morning if you're in the
market for a new pet there are dozens if
not hundreds of colorful professional
websites advertising the cutest puppies
you could imagine but if you're not
careful
you could join the tens of thousands of
people each year whom the Federal Trade
Commission says are being ripped off
you're such a handsome boy when Wayne
Warner and Pamela lanuza your boy wanted
to find a new puppy for their kids they
went looking where most people do a
google searched it and it popped up a
whole list I thought I found a dog Great
Dane named Madison was eight hundred
dollars got in contact your email got a
response right away then it moved to
text the Chicago couple sent the money
for the blue-eyed Great Dane through
Western Union to a company called
Wallace Great Danes they were given a
bill of sale and told that Madison would
be shipped by air carrier from South
Florida and then I got a phone call
saying the dog was stuck in Savannah
Georgia I needed to pay an additional
$1,500 for this pet carrier safe thing
and had to get three vaccinations to be
able to travel that's kind of when I was
starting to my heart started to sink we
were all excited we had gotten supplies
and you were about to get a new member
of the family yeah our first baby puppy
it's kind of like you know that there's
no dog there's no dog and there is no
walch Great Danes they're advertised
address in Fort Lauderdale is actually a
thrift shop according to the Federal
Trade Commission Wayne and Pamela are
victims of an international scam that
affects as many as 37 thousand people a
year paying an average one hundred to
one thousand dollars for dogs they'll
never see the Better Business Bureau
also says at least 80 percent of
websites advertising pets for sale
the vast majority believed to be puppies
are frauds and mostly based in West
one of the red flags also was the guy
asking for the more money for the cage
was a Virginia number and he didn't
speak very very good English consumer
watchdog groups like iPad org and pet
scams compost fake puppy sale sites
every week but new ones keep coming Sam
Aziz is one of them the site which is
still online as of this morning claims
to sell adorable and affordable
Australian Shepherds like 99%
potty-trained bandit Luna or Lola for
seven hundred and fifty dollars
this is Elsa and mrs. Anna and a
discounted dog should be a warning to
consumers says breeder Jordan Mills
what's involved in breeding these dogs
what's not involved the training the
getting them ready for their new homes
the vet visit to have the vet look them
over the vaccine mills who is bred
French bulldogs for a decade sells them
for an average of thirty two hundred
dollars through her website which
scammers duplicated two years ago to
defraud potential buyers they took my
website and they mirrored it completely
but there was no one behind it people
are putting trust in you a good deal of
money and then they're sitting there
waiting for something that doesn't exist
what kind of advice would you give
someone who wanted to get a puppy but
was afraid that they might be going to a
fraudulent website go to their home if
you can't visit the person and other
great resources to FaceTime them you
want to be able to talk to this breeder
ask them how they got into breeding get
a real history from them you're getting
one of your new family members you can
also look locally which is where Pamela
and Wayne finally found their beautiful
Great Dane Atticus he's the love of our
life he loves us as much as we love Him
I don't know I think he's going on with
me now the good news is Wayne and Pamela
did not end up losing their $800 because
they insured their purchased through
Western Union now the Better Business
Bureau though says use a credit card for
any online deposit and above all else
they say meet the dog and the breeder in
person before buying now my family had
this experience we my daughter went
online found a puppy we drove five hours
to meet the dog ended up
an empty parking lot but I have to say
of course you can also always go to your
local shelters and get a rescue that's
what we know so we went in no favorite
Sun will is getting a dog this fry
tomorrow actually you would think that
that this is a new baby coming we're
very excited about the new addition
well you're right getting it at the
shelter that's we went yeah they
interview you you have to pass it is so
exciting yeah I think any dog would want
to live in with Dawn's family cuz you
have horses man exactly why thank you
don